-You know our first guest
tonight from his work
on "Miami Vice," "Nash Bridges,"
"Watchmen," and "Knives Out.
He stars in the comedy serie
"Kenan,"
which airs Tuesday nights
at 8:30 right here at NBC.
Please welcome to the show
Don Johnson.
How are you, Don?
-I'm terrific, Seth.
How you doing?
-I'm doing fantastic.
You know, Kenan's an old frien
of mine, and I've been
a long-time fan of yours,
so I was delighted to see
you were working together.
How did you end up
in this project?
-Um...
Well, I was --
They plucked me out of
the unemployment line.
And, you know,
and it was a good choice.
But -- No, I, you know,
I got a -- I got a --
I think it probably
all started --
Lorne and I have been friend
for a long time.
And about a year ago or so -
can't remember.
COVID has made my brain mush
Lorne asked me to do
a table read with Michael Cera
And I did, and then,
I never heard from him again
So I said, "Well,
that must have been a bust."
[ Laughter ]
But then, meanwhile, this --
He called me,
and he sent me this.
He said, "Here,
take a look at this,
see what you think,
blah, blah, blah."
And here I am.
-Now we had Kenan on,
who said it is both a deligh
to work with you,
and it's also a delight
to hear stories
about your work in the '80s.
It did strike me
that maybe the "Miami Vice" se
was a little wilder
than the "Kenan" set.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
It's all a little bit hazy
[ Laughter ]
I think -- yeah.
Well, you know,
given that we pretty much
owned the city of Miami,
and --
and we had a party sequenc
in every episode,
and I was single,
and, you know,
it was kind of like, um...
You know,
it was kind of, like, joyful
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very -- I'm very happ
you don't look back on it
with any regrets.
It just seems lovely.
-I don't remember
one bad moment.
Not one.
[ Laughter ]
-I can tell you, you know,
of course, the other thing
you guys did is you develope
a style, you know,
that maybe
was accurate to Miami,
but the rest of us didn't know
anything about it.
And this is a true story.
I remember going off
to a school dance.
You know, and I was probably 11,
12 years old.
And my Dad said,
"You should roll up your sleeves
of your blazer,
'Miami Vice'-style."
Even as a kid I thought,
"I think you're wrong, Dad."
[ Laughter ]
-He -- He was wrong.
There were -- There were
a lot of fools
that were trying
to pull that off,
and, you know,
let's face it.
You know, it's a --
it's a -- it's a thing.
-Yeah.
I think it helps --
it helps a lot to look lik
Don Johnson when you want
to pull off that look.
-Yeah.
-I say that as a compliment.
-I thank you very much.
I was joking.
You know, it's very flattering
that something that I did that
was out of practical reasons -
I don't know if you're
aware of this,
but it's hotter than...
uh, in Miami.
And so I just started
taking off clothes.
The socks, the belt,
that T-shirt was just the front.
[ Laughter ]
The unstructured jackets
and the linen,
the linen clothes,
and even then, I said,
"Hey, I'm still pretty damn hot.
Okay!
These sleeves are going up."
-Well, it worked out.
I guess sometimes, yeah,
that's the mother of invention
I want to ask, as well,
you know, you guys were
doing a show
obviously on location.
Did that give you a good dea
more amount of freedom?
Because you didn't have
the sort of NBC execs around
in the way they would
if you were in L.A. or New York?
-You know -- [ Laughs ] --
it was kind of -- it was -
it was kind of being maroone
a little bit.
Because, you know,
we were up very early.
And everybody in Californi
sleeps until --
they don't even come in
until 10:00 or 11:00.
And so by the time
they would come into the office,
we already had a half a day'
work shot,
and they would be sending us
pages and changes and we'd go,
"No, no, no,
you don't understand.
That boat is already gone.
[ Laughter ]
So they'd get --
I mean, we'd make stuff up
you know, and just say,
"Oh, this is a good idea.
Let's do this."
'Cause we all came out of
independent films and stuff.
I mean, I'm not sure that we
even knew what a permit was.
We just would say,
"Oh. Well, let's crash the car
here in the middle
of this intersection.
Watch out!
There's a couple people there.
We should probably
get rid of them."
But, yeah.
We were just kind of wild me
down there, going, you know --
making a crazy show.
-Well, it's so interesting
you say that, because, you know,
I feel like people might
forget now that it was --
it did feel
so much more cinematic
than what anybody was used t
on television at the time,
and so it made sense that
you guys all came from film,
because it certainly
showed up in the product.
-Yeah, it did.
You know, there was --
And we were all, like --
It was like --
We were --
We all knew each other.
It was all kind of like,
you know, we knew that
what we were bringing
was better than what was there
And for us it wasn't really --
You know, we didn't think
about it in terms of,
"Oh, gosh,
we're starting something new."
We just started something
saying, "Well, if we're gonn
do this,
we're gonna do something
that's got some quality,
is a little more interesting
the music is better,
and the colors,
it'll actually have a film -
a film color palette, you know
where we won't use
certain colors.
Like you never saw red
in "Miami Vice."
And, well, occasionally,
I saw red,
but it was
for different reasons.
[ Laughter ]
-So, now, you know,
that was a long-running show
and then you did "Nash Bridges,"
which I, of course, remember
you did with Cheech Marin
and you guys
had incredible chemistry.
I had no idea, and maybe thi
was better known at the time
that Hunter S. Thompson
was sort of
behind the creation
of this show with you.
-Yeah, well, Hunter
was my neighbor in Aspen.
And, gratefully,
I was just out of mortar range
[ Laughter ]
-I was gonna say, he does no
sound like a great neighbor.
-He -- Well, actually,
he was a fabulous neighbor
Whenever I was out of town -
You wouldn't know this
about Hunter, but he was -
he loved animals.
And if I had a sick animal
he would --
and I was out of town --
he would come over
and sleep in the stall
with my animal, or in,
you know, wherever they were
And, you know, he'd bring a fe
animals of his own for company
And -- But, no,
he was a fabulous friend.
We were very, very close friends
for many, many years.
And one time we were sitting
around over at his house,
and probably some illegal
substances were around,
and we -- I said,
"Listen, I have this --"
Oh, he was complaining about
how he didn't have any money
And I said, "Well, look,
I got this commitment on CBS."
You know, 22 episodes.
I said, "Let's just
come up with something."
We did come up with something.
It was terrible.
But -- But he was there.
He was in the room.
So -- So, he got --
He got to get a royalty.
And we --
I took the germ of the ide
that Hunter and I did,
and we turned it
into "Nash Bridges."
-Well, that's fantastic.
What a fascinating neighbo
to have.
I have more to ask you.
We'll be right back with mor
from Don Johnson after this.